president biden mending fences and
building new relationships on the world
stage in italy mr biden is taking part
in the annual g20 summit of major
economies in rome this is the first
in-person meeting of the leaders since
the pandemic began mr biden's years of
foreign policy experience will be tested
on this visit as he seeks commitments on
issues ranging from vaccine sharing to
supply chain delays all of this is
taking place as democrats in washington
grapple with two giant pieces of the
president's domestic agenda the sharply
cut 1.75 trillion dollar social spending
plan and the trillion dollar
infrastructure bill wuijijang is
traveling with the president has more
from rome wijk good morning
good morning to you michelle and good
morning to everybody here in rome
president biden's message is that the
u.s is steadfastly committed to allies
and to face-to-face diplomacy it's a
message that apparently was received by
the italian prime minister who in his
opening remarks took a swipe at the
trump administration saying that the
previous policy of america first was
just not going to work and that the
group had faced nationalism but going at
it alone is not an option
this morning world leaders will focus on
ending the pandemic with more vaccine
sharing curbing iran's nuclear ambitions
tackling climate change and fixing the
supply chain issues driving up prices
everywhere but on friday night
the president was working to repair his
relationship with french president
emmanuel macron who called it a betrayal
when the u.s and uk struck a submarine
deal with australia in september
cancelling out an agreement with france
worth tens of billions of dollars what
we did was clumsy i was under the
impression that
france had been formed long before
earlier president biden a devout
catholic also met with pope francis
including an unusually long private
meeting that lasted for 75 minutes
you are the most significant warrior for
peace i've ever met
back home in the u.s some conservative
bishops are calling for mr biden to be
denied communion because he supports
abortion rights the president said he
and the pope did not talk about abortion
but that the pontiff said this
he just talked about the fact that he
was happy i was a good
they also spoke about the president's
proposals to confront the climate crisis
in his social spending bill which
democrats have yet to agree on despite
president biden's urgent pleas to pass
the plan this is about competitiveness
versus complacency about expanding
opportunity not opportunity to deny it's
about leading the world
or letting the world passes by
today president biden will make a push
for a global minimum tax on corporations
worldwide which could help make up some
revenue to pay for that huge spending
package and then tomorrow he heads off
to glasgow scotland for a climate summit
dana
we took the president had hoped that
that social spending package you
mentioned would be a done deal before
the climate summit so what impact of not
having an agreement uh will there be
so right before president biden came
here to italy he announced a framework
of that bill that does include 550
billion dollars to fight climate change
but that's not a bill and it's certainly
not a law so without a concrete plan it
will be tougher for him to force other
countries to push them to make
commitments as well but white house
officials insist that world leaders know
the complexities of legislation and that
the u.s is going to lead the fight to
reduce pollution dana
all right weeja jang in rome thank you
weeja